I have been dreaming of this of this
opportunity to have a boyfriend for the
longest time I was willing to do
anything to make it work really honestly
I remember thinking to myself I must
look really good while I'm crying right
now
[Music]
hi I'm Merle and today I'm going to be
talking to you about how I learned to
move on the story starts with my first
relationship I was 17 years old I didn't
have any dating experience in high
school I was actually quite an awkward
child for a very long time I was also
taller than everyone so that could be
tough this was over a summer right the
summer after my senior year of high
school I was about to go off to college
I had been dreaming of this of this
opportunity to have a boyfriend for the
longest time was very exciting for me so
I was fully in it with this guy and you
know it was very passionate because it
was my first love I gave 125 percent I
didn't really expect much from him he
was he's a great guy but you know he
didn't know how to be a boyfriend just
like I kind of didn't know how to be a
girlfriend but I was better at it than
he was anyway so very passionate very
sweet we opened up to each other a lot I
was convinced that this was like
something very special and something
that only I was experiencing and I was
willing to do anything to make it work
honestly I feel like I was like the
catch whatever so I was like you know
he's gonna want to put in everything he
can to make this thing happen because
when you're in your first relationship
in your first love you don't believe
they're going to end yeah so it was like
this magical summer all kinds of things
were happening I felt like I had this
like once-in-a-lifetime love and then
the summer came to a close he had been
pretty honest with me that he wasn't
willing to do long-distance because he
didn't think it would work but I kind of
thought I could talk him into it you
can't and you shouldn't you should never
have to talk someone into dating you it
doesn't work I really was pulling out my
best work I was crying I was sighing I
was looking long and fully into his eyes
there was all kinds of dramatics don't
go like stay because I was gonna go off
to college the next day he was crying
too like it was beautiful but it wasn't
enough for him did not break up with me
so of course I left on this very
dramatic note walking out the door I was
like
don't talk to me that like I just don't
want to even talk to you and I left
sobbing I was devastated because we had
agreed this was perfect and this was
special and this was our thing
and now he didn't want it to be our
thing anymore I didn't understand that I
took it very personally and I was
driving home drove stick-shift
at the time there's no reason for you
know know that other than I just think
it's cool
I'm from the middle of nowhere an 1,100
person town so like I was cruising the
speed limit is like 50 suggested it's
really like 70 on these long winding
roads I'm shifting I'm listening to I
don't know probably like a long us more
set The Cranberries
oh my god The Cranberries no need to
argue oh my god yeah so that was playing
on repeat in my car I'm cruising I'm
crying it's getting real and I see
something in the road up ahead like
probably like 100 meters ahead and so I
pull over I get out I see this teeny
little baby Fisher cat which get a very
bad reputation by the way when their
baby is they're super super cute its mom
had been hit by a car so it was just
like slinking around the road like in
circles didn't know where to go
so obviously I'm like all right I've got
to figure out how to save this thing
still crying so I go back to my car I
get a sweatshirt and I'm sobbing and I'm
like I'm like throwing the sweatshirt
over the little Fisher cat in the road
there's cars going by I'm missing it
with the sweatshirt I'm angry at my life
I'm angry at the Fisher cat angry of my
boyfriend ex-boyfriend and finally I'm
like throwing it over this thing
throwing it over this thing I'm like
they could have rabies I don't know and
I'm just like mortified and I'm so upset
and it feels like everything's gonna end
and I have to go to college and I don't
want to go to college I don't want to
start over I don't want to have new
friends finally I'm like alright the
sweater breath isn't gonna work I'm
gonna go back to the car I'm gonna call
my mom have her help me she's like I'm
on my way
so I walk back to where the little
Fisher cat was and it's gone now I'm
even more upset I'm looking everywhere
I'm like where is the little Fisher cat
where's the baby Fisher cat and I can't
find it anywhere and so then I'm of
course crying again now for the fridge
cat now for myself finally my mom gets
there I leave we go home can't find a
fish cat I'm devastated cry to my mom
all night the next I have to go to
school my mom and I are driving down
that road and I'm just thinking about
how things are not gonna get better and
I don't like what's happening and then
we go by where the Fisher cat was and I
can see the spot where the mom Fisher
cat got hit and then I see the baby
Fisher cat dead in the road
I just unleash I'm just like furious I
told my mom I'm like this is a bear baby
bear I don't understand why doesn't he
love me why does this Fisher get up to
die at my arms like Jesus Christ thank
God you were leaving for college so I
had this long four-hour drive with my
mom where I just kind of like got it all
out stopped being in my head about why
these things were happening to me and I
twisted it into this crazy metaphor like
with this Fisher cat which was that if
you linger around the pain and if you
hang back and you don't move on and you
just skip in circles in the road you're
gonna get hit by a car but as a dating
lesson don't stay with people that
aren't dying to be with you because it's
not gonna work I think the lesson of
moving on has been the most pivotal one
for me because things aren't going to go
your way people aren't going to love you
enough but as long as you do it's okay
[Music]